you know you and says i feel like tde
die hards we always kind of like
associate you two as like you know uh
we're always waiting for new music from
sizza and from isaiah rashad right like
we've been waiting for what says it
dropped in 2017. it's been a while since
control dropped but i feel like still
living he's still in the church
maybe that was [ __ ] one of the best
albums of the last decade for sure but
i feel like you two are kind of like
obviously there's the core tde members
and then there's isaiah rashad and sizza
and for whatever reason we always have
to wait very long times to get music
from both of you guys
we came after
like
the four horsemen or whatever the [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying right and like
after black hippy and that expectation
is pretty high
especially i think for her
being
like some r b soul pop type of [ __ ]
like she knew she had to like diversify
herself and not only separate herself
from like the boys but from all the
girls um so
her ear in her critique for herself is
higher and for me i just didn't want to
sound like them without getting the same
respect